from fresh sanctions on russia's largest
banks to a possible european ban on
russian coal the west's latest moves aim
to further punish moscow for atrocities
committed in ukraine there's nothing
less happening than major war crimes
responsible nations
have to come together to hold these
perpetrators accountable for the first
time the u.s is leveling direct
sanctions on vladimir putin's adult
daughters believed to be hiding putin's
personal assets the u.s department of
justice announced direct prosecutions of
russian oligarchs capturing a 100
million dollar yacht belonging to one of
them the justice department will use
every available tool to find you
disrupt your plots and hold you
accountable none of it has disrupted
russia's war in ukraine sanctions remain
reactionary nato leaders are wary of
doing anything that might hurt their own
economies these sanctions will not be
our last sanctions europe's top diplomat
called out the contradiction noting
since the war began europe has given
ukraine 1 billion euros in aid while
still spending 35 billion euros on
russian oil and gas
putin is able to fund this war through
the energy that has been sold to us and
has unfortunately has been doing this
for many years now
the eu has vowed to wean itself off
those supplies it may be forced to act
sooner than expected the west may also
need to consider secondary measures
against countries like china and india
who continue to trade with russia
moves with serious risks if the
sanctions go this far and it pushes
putin into a more desperate situation we
have to ask
what's next is he going to retaliate on
the battlefield it is possible that that
russia will resort to the use of
tactical nuclear weapons chemical
weapons other sorts of very powerful
weapons the emerging horrors may leave
no other choice but to take further
steps for ukraine the price of inaction
is already too high
jackson prosco global news washington